[Musique]
juillet dernier au sénat lors de la
conférence des territoires emmanuel
macron fait une annonce remarquer ce qui
est sûr c'est que les territoires en
particulier les plus ruraux ne peuvent
plus être la variable d'ajustement
d'économie il n'y aura plus de
fermetures de classes dans les écoles
primaires
[Applaudissements]
quelques mois plus tard pourtant le
gouvernement annonce 200 à 300 fermeture
en milieu rural les syndicats en compte
le double 70 départements sont concernés
le chef de l'état est accusé de ne pas
avoir tenu sa promesse 75% de notre
territoire est en cours d'abandon par
l'état par les services publics et je
crois que les fermetures d'écoles et la
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
le dédoublement des classes de cp dans
les rep et de ce1 dans les rets plus est
une bonne chose mais pas au détriment
des classes du monde rural
personne n'est dupe monsieur le ministre
et les territoires ruraux en ont assez
d'être dépouillés au profit de vos
politiques publiques
c'est un aveu de mépris de plus les
petits écoliers deschamps ne serait-il
pas égaux en droits à ceux des villes
alors je vois bien qu'on essaye
d'installer une petite musique pour
essayer un petit peu de dénigrer la
mesure de dédoublement mais le
gouvernement s'est donné les moyens de
faire et l'un et l'autre c'est à dire le
dédoublement en zone urbaine mais aussi
parfois en zone rurale et une politique
rurale volontariste à laquelle je vous
invite à vous associer
écoutez bien monsieur le ministre la
colère qui gronde et qui monte de ces
territoires qui se battent pour leur
survie et fait en sorte que le président
cesse de tenir compte le langage et
honore ses engagements
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fronde gagne les campagnes comme ici
dans l'allier où 22 fermetures de
classes sont prévues à la rentrée
prochaine
il semblerait une petite école
c'est un luxe qui ne correspondrait plus
au service public moderne du 21ème
siècle selon les critères de monsieur
mettront non non et non
la république c'est pas ça le service
public c'est pas ça la république c'est
les peu qu'ils écoles au milieu
nous avons suivi les parents d'élèves et
les élus mobilisés pendant des semaines
pour tenter de sauver leur école
[Musique]
la relève abba et le cheminot la journée
s'achève mais la classe est toujours
plein une classe menacée de fermeture
l'annoncé est tombée en février dernier
et depuis des parents d'élèves occupent
les lieux
c'est une honte à tous les jours prêt à
tout pour maintenir cette classe de cp
ce1 ouverte parce que là ça va faire
c'est la peur du pire gones c'est sa
troisième semaine
4e quatrième celui des parents une
fermeture vécue comme une injustice car
selon eux les effectifs n'ont pas baissé
après des semaines de lutte il cherche à
redonner du souffle à leur mouvement
c'est compliqué mais en même temps ça
arrive des jo on n'est pas nombreux mais
on arrive quand même à se relayer on
arrive à trouver
la mode oui il ya toujours des gens qui
sont là alors des fois on est plus
nombreux que d'autres et mais bon on
aimerait bien que ça c'est aussi bon
pour mes enfants je me bats pour
l'avenir de mon village je me bats sur
wii surtout pour mes enfants quoi
puisque lille de sortie de me connecter
banjul rural
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les c'est fait vous prenez votre retard
qui roule à la page d'habitude mais le
cahier lectures pendant ce temps là lui
si vous terminez votre conjugaison et si
vous avez fini vous prenez votre cahier
du joug vous écrivez la date opérations
vous posez les quatre camions
le jour aussi pendant la classe
l'occupation continue au fond de la
salle des parents d'élèves et des élus
du jamais vu à saint gérand de vaux
village d'à peine 400 habitants comment
est ce qu'on peut voir des buts vous
vous souvenez une phrase ça commence par
quoi louer un match nul et ça finit par
un point alors ça va pour nous aider se
mettre que le cas le premier mot dans
cette phrase le l alors aujourd'hui
cohabitent dans cette place une dizaine
de cp et de ce1
le multi niveaux est fréquent secteur
mais demain si cette classe ferme
il n'en restera plus qu'une sur les deux
que compte l'école une seule classe avec
quatre voire cinq niveaux différents
pour cette ancienne institutrice
difficile dans ces conditions de
conserver une bonne qualité
d'enseignement certaine que cela
favorisera une fuite vers le privé
ce2 cm1 cm2 20 enfants il a su plus du
tout la même chose pour travailler si on
y rajoute les cp ça fait vingt-cinq
quatre niveaux avec 20 élèves de déjà
des parcs dit moi je ne vais pas les
laisser là
donc aujourd'hui on va nous fermer une
classe si l'année prochaine au fermera
l'école dans les villes ont des doubles
par exemple les cp pour mettre que 12 et
puis nous à la campagne on va on nous
oblige à avoir des grandes classes avec
plein de niveaux c'est quand même une
logique aussi
[Musique]
l'un représente les parents d'élèves et
l'autre les enseignants ils se
retrouvent ce jour là pour faire un
point sur la rentrée 2010 8
tous deux sont opposés à la future carte
scolaire
à chaque fois qu'on crée un poste en
éducation prioritaire on ferme une
classe ailleurs avec leur système on
peut pas accepter ça ils en sont sûrs
les fermetures sont la conséquence des
classes à 12 ans rep en réseau
d'éducation prioritaire pour tous les cp
et ce1 que situés en zone urbaine
sensible
une promesse de campagne d' emmanuel
macron parce que son appellation envers
tursan comprise en fait les
dédoublements de rep tout à fait ça dort
laly 22 classes seront supprimées et 21
ouvertures prévues pour des chiffres
contestés par les syndicats pour eux les
dédoublements ne sont pas des ouvertures
de classes il ne compte que 10 ouverture
réelle sur les vingt-et-une annoncé et
dénonce une réforme mal anticipé et non
budgétées en plaçant les fed annonce on
va des doublés dans l'éducation
prioritaire
là tout de suite on s'est dit allez voir
un problème 6 à moyens constants et ben
voilà le problème
on est en plein dedans on n'est pas
contre les dédoublements dans
l'éducation prioritaire mais la façon
dont ça se passe c'est ces terribles
quoi
donc la carte scolaire qu'on a cette
année elle est qualitativement plus
grave que les précédentes et du coup là
on a des mobilisations de défense du
territoire des services publics et du
cadre de vie et de la démocratie locale
tout ça étant liés
[Musique]
m
le directeur académique de l'allier lui
s'en défend et assure que les
dédoublements en rep n'ont pas provoqué
de fermeture ailleurs que la ruralité a
même été largement prises en compte
ce redéploiement se fait pas uniquement
dans le cas de l'éducation prioritaire
sur les 21 ouvertures neuf ouvertures
seulement sont consacrés aux
dédoublements tout le reste on est sûr à
la fois des déplacements de population
et puis parfois des situations où il est
nécessaire parce qu'il ya un contact
social particulier de renforcer les
moyens lors ce qui est assez paradoxal
c'est que sur les 21 ouvertures on a un
son de verture qui sont dans la réalité
on a six ouvertures de classes dans
leurs actes il garantit qu'aucun emploi
n'a été retiré dans le département
malgré la baisse démographique cette
baisse si elle devait correspondre à des
retraits d'emplois à moins d'enseignants
et bien ça voudrait dire entre 60 et 80
fermetures de classes avec un ratio de
vingt-et-une couverture et 22 fameux
tueur on n'a aucun retrait d'emploi ça
signifie qu'on protège lançons des
écoles
comme beaucoup de villages ruraux saint
gérand de vaux a longtemps perdu des
habitants
mais depuis peu la démographie repart
doucement
la mairie a acheté des terrains pour
construire un lotissement et ainsi
attirer de jeunes familles et donc
d'autres centre-bourg il faut
l'hospitaliser puisque ce sens ainsi
dans l'air du temps et de ses skis chez
les gens vont venir à saint jean oui
donc il faut à tout prix on achète on
achète les bâtis on arrive à acheter des
bâtiments jolie nahla sa pente douce
voilà donc ce sera très bien travaillé
souvent sans courant et la non ce jour
là le maire de saint gérand de vaux
réuni ses adjoints pour parler de la
réhabilitation du coeur du village
un projet qui mise sur le patrimoine
pour améliorer le cadre de vie
nous allons travailler sur le sur notre
bourg pour le rendre plus accessible aux
gens est plus attractif en tombant des
ruines et c'est en l'embellissant et
puis on va travailler sur l'économie si
l'économie et le tourisme
donc on sent sommes un pays de des temps
de château le tourisme vert est
important l'un étant qui tourne super
bien nous on n'en on axe beaucoup sur le
tourisme et les piles activité
économique parce que c'est votre commune
aussi nous avons une magnifique
entreprises de 50 salariés et des
petites entreprises qui vient de
s'installer donc avec 60 salariés sur la
commune qui n'habitent pas encore la
commune
on a des minots fera alors forcément la
fermeture d'une classe est vu comme une
menace
tous redoutent l'impact désastreux sur
la vie du village risque c'est que des
parents s'en aille
des parents avec des enfants et donc
toute la mise en oeuvre dans notre
projet de territoire pour le vélo donc
il faut à tout prix que l'on conserve
nos habitants et des enfants qui vont
avec
il faut même au contraire qu'on accentue
la l'évolution de la commune au niveau
démographique
on croit rural est persuadé que beaucoup
de gens reviendront sur l'oral
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trente kilomètres plus loin
habib loi la nouvelle est tombée
tardivement la classe du village fait
elle aussi partie de la liste noire des
fermetures dans l'allier sauf qu'ici
fermer une classe veut dire fermer
l'école tout le village a décidé de se
battre on va faire du café alors ouhlala
d'accord une classe unique allant du cp
au cm2 une dizaine d'élèves des
conditions jugées idéal pour bien
apprendre d'eux oui alors que les
enfants en cours juste à côté
commence une nouvelle journée
d'occupation et la salle écoles à fermer
donc ça me semble légitime quand on
entame ce combat là et ça me semble pas
insurmontable pour les institutions de
revenir sur une fermeture d'école sais
pas ce que vous en pensez mais ça je
pense que le combat mérite d'être mené
en 2014 déjà le village s'étaient
mobilisés pour éviter la suppression
d'une des deux classes mais cela n'avait
pas suffi et le montant avait 70
[Musique]
d'après la direction académique
les enfants ne sont pas assez nombreux
pour maintenir la classe ouverte
il faut plus d'élèves à la rentrée
prochaine on est toujours à la recherche
de ses seize élèves 1 pour atteindre le
seuil les le quota quand on nous a
imposé qu'on nous demande donc voilà ça
il faut pas perdre de vue cet objectif
là non plus donc
parlez-en autour de vous à vos amis à
votre famille
et puis on va essayer d'obtenir c'est c
'est inscriptions
d'une part pour conserver notre
institutrice qui est juste
exceptionnelle et puis d'autre part bien
sûr pour conserver cette école qui est
le coeur et le poumon du village une
classe minimum de 16 élèves pour sauver
l'école les parents d'élèves ont fait le
tour des familles du village pour tenter
de les motiver à inscrire leurs enfants
habiles soit il faut aller chercher les
inscriptions une par une
on a fait un point sur sur l'état civil
donc on a recensé les enfants qui sont
toujours sur la commune est prêt à être
scolarisés donc pas sur l'année
prochaine puisque c'est là que le bât
blesse mais sur l'année d'après l'année
d'encore après nous avons pour l'instant
pour l'année prochaine huit inscriptions
fermes et définitives enregistrées en
mairie et en faisant le tour des
familles nous avons récupéré déjà quatre
enfants supplémentaires qui sont
scolarisés pour l'instant à l'extérieur
ça peut paraître peu de passer de 8 à 12
mais quand on passe de huit enfants à 12
c 50% de l'effectif en plus c'est pas
rien c'est difficile pour nous parents
élus et habitants de d'entendre parler
de seuils ou de quotas quand il s'agit
de la scolarité des enfants
on devrait vraiment replacer l'enfant au
l'intérêt de l'enfant au coeur du débat
ce qui n'a pas été fait par les
représentants de l'éducation nationale
selon leurs calculs à la rentrée 2010 9
il y aura dix sept enfants et en 2020 21
alors ils réclament un nom de sursis
pour pouvoir sauver l'école on n'arrive
pas à leur faire admettre quand on a un
soucis d'effectif uniquement pour la
rentrée 2010 8,1
ça c'est quelque chose qui ne veulent
absolument pas entendre donc on va
continuer de leur expliquer jusqu'à ce
qu'il veuille bien le comprendre
voilà moi j'ai été dans cette école et
j'aurais voulu que mes enfants fassent
pareil je suis très attaché en fait au
niveau de l'école et de la commune cette
maman aussi est très attaché sans
l'école amandine ne se serait pas
installé à bille loi avec sa famille il
y a une dizaine d'années ma petite pente
au fond chacun met le couvert
si l'école ferme
elle ne sait pas où sa fille pourra être
scolarisés et elle se refuse à l'idée de
prendre davantage sa voiture des écoles
aux alentours de nous mais qui ne sont
géographiquement pas forcément proche
pas sur les trajets que les personnes
font pour aller à leur travail et les
écoles qui éventuellement pour accepter
nos enfants sont des écoles qui sont
déjà en surnombre donc forcément des
classes surchargées ça engendre une
moins de temps disponible pour les
enfants donc à mon sens une qualité
d'enseignement qui sera moindre et on
n'est pas prêts à renoncer à la qualité
qu'on a nous chez nous inquiète pour
l'avenir de l'école publique et de son
village aussi tu feras tu es belle souci
sectera vu que mercredi s'est pas
ouverte en a pas jeudi c'est la grève
donc si nelly bassiner liste donne des
choses pour vendredi oui si tu veux
regarder ce soir à la garderie tu
t'avances on se dit forcément que vinci
a plus d'école les gens vont y regardent
à deux fois donc on risque d'avoir aussi
bien notre population qui va diminuer
donc ça engendre tout un tas de notes de
choses néfastes
on partira pas de notre campagne parce
qu'on est de notre campagne mais on veut
pas être privé de la chance qu'on a à
rosy oui ça veut dire un village qui va
mourir parce que ça veut dire des
personnes du troisième âge qui vont
décéder et puis une population qui se
refera pas donc c'est une commune qui
est voué à voué à mourir tout simplement
alors pourtant on a des terrains on a
tout ce qu'il faut on a une équipe de
foot on a un stade on a quand même des
épiceries qui sont pas on a notre
épaissi proximité on a des supermarchés
qui sont pas loin on a tout ce qu'on
peut rêver d'avoir en ayant la qualité
de la vie de campagne tout en ayant des
choses à proximité quand même ben pour
le quotidien mais l'école on en a qu'une
[Musique]
c'est revigorant d'aujourd'hui
la patronne amis qui sont venus ce matin
[Musique]
ce jour là le sénateur gérard dériot est
venu rendre visite aux maires et aux
parents l'occasion pour le maire d'
exprimer son désarroi sur messieurs
bonjour les parents il fait visiter la
cantine scolaire construite par la
mairie il y a quelques années et qui
deviendra inutile si l'école ferme tout
l'équipement une dizaine d'année 2007
ici c'est un pro oui les choses
donc là on démissionne en même temps on
a décidé justement de transformer a fait
1 0 pour adapter une cantine scolaire
m'honore et ça c'est un investissement
qui écoute et quand même 40 millions
euros gage le docteur dons et des
subventions de désulfuration fut un beau
temps c'est marc souviennent
un gâchis assure-t-il alors que tout a
été financé avec de l'argent public
la fin de la cantine c'est aussi mettre
un terme à l'emploi de la cantinière qui
travaille là depuis des années
si l'école ferme qu'est ce que je vais
faire mon agent savait très bien qu'on
peut pas licencier un fonctionnaire donc
le problème et je ne sais pas par quels
moyens
je vais résoudre ce problème d'argent
s'il a plus d'école ya plus de ménages
et plus de cantine je vais pas lieu
d'avoir quelqu'un que payer deux arrêts
rien faire quoi habile soit l'école et
le dernier service public encore présent
le sénateur dénonce une fois de plus une
attente à la ruralité bien pour un maire
et pour des élus municipaux comme
disait qu'ils le font pratiquement
bénévolement et qui se défoncent pour
avoir de l'activité pour avoir une école
dans leur commune
il est certain que c'est très très très
désarmant et que ça peut mettre un peu
en colère mais un peu beaucoup même des
parents d'élèves paris au mois de
juillet le président de la république
annonce qui aura plus de fermetures
d'écoles primaires en zone rurale ça
sera plus la variable d'économies
et puis finalement on se retrouve
exactement avec l' inverse
là on reste sur un aspect très générale
et comprenez que nous on n'a plus le
temps de traiter cet aspect général on
est on est sous le coup d'une fermeture
d'une école qui meurt c'est un village
qui meurt oui mais ça je sais on a
besoin de soutien et houleux ce cas vous
l'aurez je vous inquiétez pas je ferai
le nécessaire auprès du directeur de
l'académie et ben c'est à dire que je
vais lui demander qui puisse au moins
faire une exception les élus en
particulier sont quand même très inquiet
car on a quand même le sentiment qu'avec
le gouvernement actuel tout est à peu
fait pour les villes les métropoles en
plus et au détriment de l'âme du monde
rural delà des zones disons
interstitielle entre les centres urbains
et pour cela on n'a pas le sentiment
vraiment qu'il ya une volonté de pouvoir
redonner de l'activité dans ces parties
du territoire
[Musique]
c'est le dernier commerces encore
ouverts au village l'auberge qui existe
depuis plus de 30 ans mais seul un bon
jour
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur etienne les habitants
ont l'habitude de s'y retrouver aussi
bien pour prendre le café que faire
leurs courses
c'est l'école ferme on aura plus rappelé
ce mouvement surtout que j'appelle tous
quand même le bal du pôle de journaux je
fais tes légumes
j'ai fait à peine de s'achever l'école
ici chez deuxième c'est quand même le
lieu de rencontre le cias il ya du lien
social dans la commune
parce que etienne maintienne son
commerce il un commerce menacé lui aussi
par la fermeture de l'école car c'est
l'épicerie qui fournit les denrées
permettant de préparer les repas à la
cantine et le manque à gagner pourrait
être source de difficultés financières
enfin cette satire tort à mort en
premier puis à tous et qu'ils aient tous
les gens du village où ci après c'est
pour ça faut faire quelque chose il faut
se battre pour garder tous les petits
commerces que tout le moins le besoin de
tout le monde
impensable pour ses habitants de voir ce
dernier service de proximité disparaître
ça fait effet boule de neige en fait
une école puis des berges et
d'associations huit vit dans le village
comme une morte
labeaume ignore aussi à beaucoup quand
même de service public n'a disparu est
de plus en plus on veut la mort dans
deux communes
parce que si on enlève des services ça
veut dire que dans quelques temps de la
mairie seront fermés hier dans un four
mères disent avoir les prochaines
élections motors la montée du prix à
[Musique]
l'avenir est incertain mais il refuse de
céder à la résignation
bien décidé à se battre pour que leurs
villages restent vivants
[Musique]